hey guys I wanted to take a second and
let you guys know that the young turks
is moving Studios you know the Reuben
report is part of the young turks
network we are the largest online
network in the world The Young Turks
show that jank started is a huge
resource for telling the truth fighting
the power trying to get money out of
politics all things that i absolutely
believe in nothing that we do around
here are we ever barked orders at i
don't have anything in my ear right now
telling me what to say like they do on
mainstream news and and I think we're
truly doing something that's important
and relevant here so we're moving new
studios and we're trying to raise a
little money to make that happen because
did you know that they want money when
you're when you're moving studios
there's equipment and things and people
like to get paid so we're hoping that
you guys will help us do this if you did
what we do we can't we can get bigger we
can get better but we need your help so
we've got a link for an indiegogo
campaign that we're doing it's right
down below in the description and i hope
you guys will give what you can if you
are entertained by anything I do or if
you feel like you've learned a little
something and you have you know a couple
bucks you can spare it will be
appreciated and we can we can truly
truly as janko he says I mean we can
change the world by telling the truth by
fighting the power and hopefully
entertaining you along the way so again
there's an IndieGoGo link down there and
we appreciate whatever you can give and
if you can't give well then just how
about you click like you click like then
we'll go from there alright thanks